I don't buy the argument about the
social pressure there's a sort of
standard view yeah inflation is
important and of course it is consistent
with a lot of things we're finding
including isotropy when I read of a a
new experimental result my very first
reaction is how can I show this is wrong
I'll give you an example I was sent a
paper to review which claimed that
because of some complicated Theory there
had to be a strong anisotropy in the
gamma ray background so I did the
calculation and discovered that if I
simply held up a plate full of raw eggs
the gamma rays that this guy was
predicting would be present would cook
it instantly I think a lot of us have
that sort of skeptical how can I show
this is wrong attitude and are not
terribly High Bound by the sort of
prevailing Orthodoxy let's call it